vancouver unfortunately i have to
reschedule there's a lot that goes on to
getting in and out of our countries and
until that's a little easier
i'm gonna have to postpone the vancouver
and the edmonton shows
um but
thursday march 3rd i will be at zany's
for one night only and friday march 4th
and saturday march 5th i'll be in
lexington get all your tickets at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media if you're watching the show
please hit the subscribe button i can't
tell you how much it means to us it's
nothing if especially if you're strapped
and you're like ryan you hit me up so
much how can i help the show i don't
have any money hit subscribe that's it
means nothing to you and everything to
us all right the patreon show
i got to keep telling you about the
patreon show it's one of my favorite
things to do i absolutely love my job uh
the honeydew with y'all
and i'm highlighting the lowlights with
y'all and y'all have not let me down man
the stories continue to come in it is a
wild wild show if you subscribe it's
five bucks a month if you're staying for
a year you get over a month free and
you're getting the honeydew a day early
ad free at no additional cost i haven't
raised the price we're keeping it at
that so go subscribe today and if you or
someone you know has that story that has
to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com alright you
guys know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers i'm very excited to have
this guest back on the honeydew ladies
and gentlemen please welcome back george
perez everybody welcome back to the
honeydew what's up my boy thank you so
much for having me back to all the
sickler fans out there thanks man like
hey i'm back you are back and before i
say anything else
give me a little love brother thank you
congrats on being a paid regular at the
comedy center thank you hey we're made
men dogs we did it the same night to get
not not only did we go in together we
did it the same night and i brought you
up yeah and let me tell you dude you
[ __ ] slayed i've been saying you had
the best there's no hands down the best
set of the night not just to the
showcases you had the best set of the
night you shredded that thank you
brother hey you know what i i wanna
you're not lying because somebody came
up to me and they're like yo sickler was
giving you props in the main room in the
green room about your grandma getting
deported joke 100 that [ __ ] really
happened i know and that's what i'm
saying was uh the only
the police raided the house and the only
illegal thing in there was your crap
smoking weed on her taking her ass out
of there i remember the line only graham
i ever lost i was like yeah that's a
great joke that's the [ __ ] i remember
sometimes i can't remember people's
names whatever like dude dude that bit
that means more to me anyway i don't
give a [ __ ] you know my name's ryan or
brian i don't give a [ __ ] anyway
congrats on being a paid regular at the
world famous comedy store it's a big
deal fun to go on with you thank you bob
and check out george's last episode
where uh salt off sundays was uh coined
it was a great episode uh but if you
want to promote anything now please do
everything you want up top yeah uh
follow me on instagram twitter uh if
you're married you probably still have a
facebook with your wife it's george p
comedy
uh youtube george perez stories also
follow fools gone wild that's who our
tour with i tour with fool's gone wild
and the funk freaks
and uh hey i'm back we're gonna go into
detail about everything and it's it's on
yo paid regulars my boy paid regulars uh
um all right so last time we were here
we talked about a lot of the [ __ ] you
did that landed you in prison and we
talked uh touched on prison
uh but i i was telling you before we
record i'm fascinated by prison i love
all the locked up shows i love locked up
abroad what do you think of those shows
i knows i know it's a little bit hokey
and [ __ ] like that but but i also can't
believe there was a person
that was convinced to do the [ __ ] these
people have done i know
you know i'm watching this guy over in
like [ __ ] brazil and i'm like you're
about to put two pounds of heroin up
your [ __ ] you know i'm i know i'm not
even part of it and i'm getting anxiety
like this [ __ ] it's crazy yeah
so
i as a person my whole goal is to never
i don't even want to do jail never go to
prison jail and prison are different
[ __ ] neighbors yeah they're they're
way too different because when you're in
jail
you're how can i say it governed or
you're the people in charge you are
sheriffs
and they know you're not going to be
there too long
now when you're in prison they're
correctional officers you're detained in
jail you're living in prison oh yes it's
two different [ __ ] like when you're in
the county
your clothes all that crap it's not to
go with you when you go to prison it's a
whole new thing so i was saying to you
like
i want to talk more about this lifestyle
because there are people who want to go
to prison you're like i know those fools
i'm like yeah there are peoples whose
sole purpose in their life is like i
want to go live in that institution yeah
they play monopoly and they get to get
out of jail card and they burn it get
this [ __ ] out of here have you seen guys
literally that could get out and just or
went right back is that what you mean
they get out and they go right back in
yeah it's it's it's a whole different
system i mean it's
like it's kind of like the army bro
that's what i'm saying it's an
institution yeah for sure and then all
right so talk to me walk us through the
first day
you're going to prison not jail are you
ready for this [ __ ] day one i won't
forget it bro because i don't remember
if you told us
okay uh
christmas eve
already
christmas eve's house and i'm [ __ ] i
shaved the night before because i know
my family's gonna come visit me it's
friday what did they get you for they
got me for uh this last one was
uh
assault
aggravated assault street terrorism gang
enhancements and a gbi great bodily
injury okay what first of all what is a
street terrorism street terrorism is uh
in that era if you're considered a gang
member and you were with more than two
three people they made up a term yeah
hell yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
i look indian but i'm not he's a
terrorist not a street terrorist yeah a
street type and this happened at the
basketball court so yeah two different
[ __ ] but uh yeah they got me for that
and then the gbi is a great bodily
injury and what did you do to that
person uh can you say i know yeah i
could say it no i could say this because
it's already done so i broke his eye
socket right here
he had to have like a plate and i guess
it's connected to like your breathing
passages so that his foot pumped it up
he showed up the [ __ ] court like
darth vader
remember when they found him
yeah
yeah and i was tr even i was like [ __ ]
like you were breathing when i left
but hey i beat him up so bad i told
myself get in the [ __ ] car
you're like
a lot of people don't know this but the
real reason i was defending defending is
my son was on the [ __ ] playground
this wasn't even gangster [ __ ] there was
two men playing basketball no and this
full thought he could punk me and i'm
good in basketball i was i'm not good no
more i can't play but i was scoring on
them clowning them and you know
this is be right before i become a
comedian but i still have those comedo
like burns like
you know how it is yeah when you're a
man and you're getting burned by another
man and yeah and i just had to whip his
ass
and yeah so i got locked up for all that
[ __ ] but
going to prison [ __ ] man now why is okay
i want to ask you this what was it a
culmination of all the [ __ ] that you've
done up to this point plus this to put
you in prison or is this if you had been
clean with this one offense be prison
worthy
the only reason it was prison worthy is
because of the gbi got it okay that
comes like
they should i should have done six years
years yeah because a gbi is a three-year
enhancement like yo you [ __ ] did like
enhancement i love that that's the word
you know that [ __ ] gisele jizzalin i
don't even know her name but for who
though huh that's an enhancement for
whom enough for the system yeah yeah the
more money of course keep the bed full
yes and uh
yeah man i was in the county cause you
got to go to county
for your trial i fought this [ __ ]
and then you were fighting a lot
that's what got you there in the first
place the only one i lost
that's the only one i lost
so before this though
i mean
i had great parents bro it's a lot of
people say it's apparent i had great
[ __ ] parents man my mom used to look
for me at night with knives and [ __ ]
even my friends were like yo your mom's
looking for you dog the gang bangers are
sad
like yo your mom's looking for you with
a bat and a knife and i was like [ __ ] i
had to sneak into my own house and be
like i was in the room the whole time
what are you talking about
so uh
we're gonna go now to my first day in
prison
it's friday i won't forget it
it's like [ __ ] two in the morning
and the cops like perez you're catching
the chain catching the chain means is
you're gonna go upstate to wasco prison
and
it's showtime dog and they and they're
just like look don't [ __ ] bring
underwear just [ __ ] wear your
jumpsuit
[ __ ] sandals and that's it you're not
none of this you're you're and i was
like all right whatever and you're
allowed to take keep your the letters
and pictures that your family you know i
was writing my family letters they were
writing me i got to keep all that
and what hey
damn i'm like a weird flashback it's
like a weird train riding and everyone's
you're on a train no i'm not a bus it
felt like a train because the bus is old
and you're all seeing that bus on the
highway yeah i've seen it and you're
like chained bro to what the seat no to
each other so it's called the catching
the chain so like
i'm handcuffed my hands and feet are
handcuffed okay the guy next to me is
handcuffing there's a [ __ ] chain
going through all of us every single oh
i see kind of like one goes you all
gotta go
remember marshall harrison ford and [ __ ]
like
it was like that got it
and you know and is it two per seat is
that yeah
and this thing snakes through all of you
yeah and
it's already race separated right now
you're like they already know like they
got the blacks hole there they got the
whites over here and you got the others
over here and the others yeah you know
other you know what others are uh-uh so
they have a group called others
where they don't associate their
politics with no one they're just in
their own lane doing [ __ ] because like
how in the [ __ ] are you going to be
mexican if you're from russia
there's like so that's where it breaks
off so
we get to wasco
that's probably what 20 degrees i'm
[ __ ] freezing bro we're outside and
they're like hey this is it you're no
longer our property you belong to the
state and we walk into are you [ __ ]
are you scared i'm [ __ ] scared as
[ __ ] but in my face i'm just like sure
bring this [ __ ]
bring this [ __ ] talking about yeah cause
i watched some [ __ ] today where a was a
woman's prison she walked in you could
see the fear on this lady's face and i
was like they're gonna kick your ass
yeah
but you know you also have this thing
where you know some people in there at
the time right i mean so i know that's a
little
comforting but i couldn't imagine going
in being like i don't know anybody in
there that i could trust or even ask
questions so it's on your face i'm hard
but inside you're like i'm [ __ ] oh my
god all that [ __ ] got stripped from me
cause when i walked in i thought it was
gonna be like [ __ ] uh
shawshank redemption where y'all walk in
and they're all laughing at you and [ __ ]
no you walk into a building and there's
women walking there's women in there
doing the reception and they're like get
naked right now i was like they're like
get naked and then now there's 300 naked
[ __ ]
and they're like all right boom check
they checked all my tattoos because
they're they're they're profiling you
where they're gonna send you
they're like all right where can i send
this for oh
yeah
and you know me everyone says i've never
been a gang member or nothing they're
like what's that tattoo that tattoo then
they go to this chart and they're like
okay we know who you are we know where
you're going and they boom
as soon as i get up there the lady was
just like what's your name boom she
looked it up there's a [ __ ] fight bro
what do you mean
so while you're standing there talking
to this lady a fight breaks yeah
it didn't even break out in the building
it broke out on the yard
i haven't even been to prison yet like
you're in the reception of it and they
they had to bring this this white boy
man oh man oh man it was like swole ass
white boy
got brought in his face was like
completely just red all
and i was just
like all right homie it's going down in
my head i was just like hey man it's
going down all right cool and then
that's when everyone just they separated
us because they didn't know if it was
going to ricochet in there with us
because you know the whites seen their
own boy [ __ ] up and they're like what
happened and he was just like he was
just they they put him in a cage
separate i don't know what was going on
he owed money what the [ __ ] it was but
that was my first
experience of like a dog they kill
like they kill here you know what i'm
saying yeah and then yeah i know exactly
that's what i'm scared of yeah so for
anyone i've watched some [ __ ] i don't
mean to interrupt no you watch some [ __ ]
where
and i've talked about this before where
i learned like
whites here blacks here
uh mexicans here and like if you this is
the end literally the end of the bunk
bed this guy was standing over here but
facing him doing [ __ ] but his feet were
in the mexican side it's over and they
kept telling them yo so they finally
went to the leader of the white the
whites and was like if your boy does
this [ __ ] again we're taking him out and
he was new so they went to him and said
look we don't know you we don't give a
[ __ ] about you this is your last warning
if you go over there you're not starting
trouble for us we're letting them [ __ ]
you up and then he got it right away you
know yeah see what should have happened
and i'm not trying to tell any race how
to do it but if that was in my situation
i would have went up to the guy but i
homie you're new huh hey check it out
man you're one of us now you represent
us
so let me give you a little bit of
skeleton yeah scratch i mean schooling
but see the mexicans did that they were
cool about it at first and that's why
they were upset like homeboy keeps doing
it yeah we told him once that's it in
prison one [ __ ] time
yeah i'm scared of i couldn't i don't
think i could go to sleep but that's
what i want to get to next all right so
get through today because i want to know
about the first time you don't even want
to do it that's not sad like
i'm gonna stay awake until my body just
collapses
okay so after that they give you a
laundry bag
because you're in reception wasco is a
reception and a prison yard reception is
they're gonna interview you
and let you know like hey this was a
[ __ ] cycle we got to put him in a
ward
excuse me
or they're like you know what this guy
he's like a gangster but i can see
it's just an evaluation
my points were too high
i was in there for a violent crime
so
the point system is i think it's one
through 18 you're on a level one yard
that's where like when tommy chong got
locked up he was locked up in fairfield
it's a level one yard no real criminals
as far as like abusive
level two yard is the same [ __ ] but you
know it's
but the three and the four ryan
it's [ __ ]
yeah
it is bro it's like and wash goes a
three and a four yard
just that yeah but the whole place
you're in is nothing but aggressive yeah
[ __ ] convicts yeah and there every
yard has a one yard because it's the
workers and [ __ ] cuz you can't let these
other guys work in the kitchen they'll
[ __ ] kill each other right yeah
the point here yeah so you have to have
one yarders there okay and
but oh dude so they give me my laundry
bag and [ __ ] and i'm like
and one of the homies is like i know
people there but they're not my friends
right they're like fools i used to
gangbang with when i was younger and
they're like what's up homie i thought
you're doing comedy what are you doing
here and i was like i guess the jokes
didn't work
and then i was like you know some
[ __ ] i did something i got i got
caught up in
and i knew i was only doing three years
so you like they ask you how much time
are you doing and that's where you got
to be super respectful so you got
reduced from six to three no i only got
three because i got a great lawyer and
when i went to court the judge was like
you know what man
you haven't been in trouble in 12 years
george you're
a father
you're doing good so many people wrote
letters for me
and he was like i'm just gonna give you
three years and i was like oh [ __ ]
isn't it crazy that you're thanking
somebody for three years ago i wrote him
i wrote him i was in prison his name was
judge wapner nuh-uh yeah he was in
newport not the people's court yeah yeah
i said everyone was like no i'm not
making this [ __ ] up
judge waffles the og people score
think of that [ __ ] i don't even think it
wasn't him he was a retired judge no
this guy was
you know i don't ever judge nobody for
being racist
this guy had no racist bone in him i
could feel it he can't fair judge yeah
yeah like he was like he was just he
wrote me back too he was just like you
know what i hope you do good in your
life i took a chance on you guy
and i was like i'm not hey i got your
back i got he wrote me back bro i wrote
him he's like gotta invite him to if
he's still alive bring him out to the
comedy store man yeah
oh i got you i love how you always i
could go i seen them later when i went
to my brother's court but anyways
so you get your laundry bag and now
they're taking you to your [ __ ]
prison cell
once the gate opens
there's signs on the wall that say no
warning shots
oh my god everything i'm scared of
everything and there's these guys in
towers with [ __ ] ar-15s ready just
if you put your foot on the fence they
have a right to shoot you and that's
called an escape now one foot i see
that's considered an escape one
tie in that shoe or something yeah like
i i would look at the fence and be like
it's the first time a mets can see in a
fence and i was like man
i'm good
so
i get to the
the craziest yards in wasco
are d4 and d5
d5 is now the whole the shoe program or
i was in d4
so what does that mean
d4 is 23 hour lockdown
all because of this aggressive charge no
it's enhancement it's just how it is
that's how it starts or that's just how
prison goes that's it's a reception so
they know like hey if we let these
[ __ ] out shit's gonna crack
okay we can't literally we we didn't
even get yard like it was just one hour
a day one hour and and check this out
all my enemies live under me
under me on the floor below yeah right
there and there and then there's a van
and they're talking [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i can't wait and
the way me and my people are we don't
say nothing we avoided like yeah okay
whatever we put like little
paper over the van we have to hear them
sometimes and
i get there there's some [ __ ] lame
ass fool that was my sally i couldn't
stand this full how many in a cell
that's what i wanted okay
it's too dangerous yeah and this guy was
a weirdo bro like weirdo like he was
trying to scare me
but that's beyond that this is my first
night
like mental like trying to get weird on
you like crazy
yeah well he was trying to scare me
because he was hiding something i
figured it out later i'm like what the
[ __ ] what this was what's this fool
hiding
and uh i i told her hey dog
let's get down when you're when you're
in prison
and it's your own people you have to be
like hey look i have a problem with you
so get your knife and i'll get mine and
we'll just go at it
and then i'm cool or we can fight
one-on-one
and i told him hey dawg we're gonna have
to get down
and then he pushed the button and left
like you could tell the cops hey i'm in
my fear and i want to get out of here
but the first night we're there
yeah i want to get to falling asleep
eventually i get i didn't get a chance
to fall asleep you clean your bunk i'm
talking you better clean this [ __ ] like
if it's a garage sale toy god i can't
imagine you know what i mean so i got my
soap i got a rag i [ __ ] cleaned it
all i cleaned the floor i cleaned
everything put my mattress [ __ ] on
then i'm i'm
i'm kind of tripping because it's
freezing and all you have is a jumpsuit
so the homies are hey put a t-shirt over
your head it's going to get cold wrap it
on your head wear your jacket when you
sleep and i was like i don't want to get
this [ __ ] wrinkled but i want to live
so i'm about to put my jacket on and
then i don't know nowhere the [ __ ]
gooners come in the gooners are like the
swat team of probation of
correction officers i guess the day
before i was in prison
our people
jumped the cops oh man
and the guy who started it is the guy's
cell i came into that's why they kicked
him out ah okay that's what he was
hiding so i haven't even laid in my bed
yet and they [ __ ] go to my room rip
all my sheets off to see if we had
weapons
i just cleaned that yeah
and then when they search you they put
you out on the yard and you have to go
through a metal detector because
sometimes people have metal in them
and that was my first [ __ ] night and
then i just i i i remember like walking
back and [ __ ] and it's like
ah [ __ ] how old was i when i went in i
was 30.
and uh
it's just a trip because there was fools
there
that were like
monsters bro
like you could just
and one of them was like tell me about
the baddest dude in d5 d4 iv he was uh
i'm not gonna give up my homie but there
was an enemy in there that was [ __ ]
crazy i mean was there a guy in there
you just everyone everyone regardless of
race or whatever was like that [ __ ]
guy he's the baddest [ __ ] like
if you had to have prison against prison
fights who's the one dude that's
wrapping this prison
i don't know because there were some
tough ones yeah but there was one dude
that came out on the news while we were
watching it
he was from bakersfield
he was from a gang called country cowboy
crips
and this fool went into the [ __ ] club
looked at the camera and was like what's
up my boy and just [ __ ] boom boom
boom boom boom shot that [ __ ]
drank a beer
and left damn and it came out on the
news while we were there because they
housed them at wasco where we were at
and he was a disrespectful ass fool
and uh
i won't forget this fool he's probably
doing life i mean he has to be but like
yeah he was a [ __ ] he was a piece of
[ __ ] dude like uh
so if he's our enemy and any door opens
i have to [ __ ] run out there
that's the way it works yeah tell him i
know you can't say everything but no but
like so
say me and you are sellies your name's
uh rain
will call me raul i'll take raul that
was my name in spanish class rahul
the teacher said there is no ryan in
spanish she's like i'm gonna call you
rahul i go what is that she goes ralph i
was like god damn but i'll take it
all right so we're cell mates
by the way you're locked up with one
person for 20 those 23 hours you're with
somebody yeah that would drive me nuts
well it's it's a whole
it's kind of like we're at war so it's
like
say me and you were locked up
it'd be cool because i'd be like hey so
check this out
what's your schedule like brother when
do you want to work out when do you want
to eat so i give you the whole space
i'll lay on my bed for you for four
hours and then you lay on your bed for
me for four hours that way i can read
when you're on your bed you read a book
you write a letter to your loved ones
it's like a it's a camaraderie it's like
yo homie this is us
but that fool that i had first wasn't he
wasn't with the program so i had to like
let him know man
and uh yeah bro so that guy that was
that kill that fool
he decided to piss on one of our doors
because they give you a day room
and
he pissed on one of our doors and next
chance we had we got that full out of
there
just attacked them yeah damn fool you
brought back some crazy memories
you need more water
yeah man uh
you know it was a trip though too ryan i
seen childhood friends in there in that
prison
because after i was in d4 they moved me
to a1
now that's prison mainline life
like where i was at
the cops are like we're not going to
deal with you guys you're going to be in
yourself for 23 hours you're going to
take hour to [ __ ] take a shower or
say hi do whatever you gotta do and you
go back in
now in this other place
sell living more people okay now how
long are you before you moved into that
area
it matters it took me
three months man you were on lockdown 23
hours a day for three [ __ ] months
dude i did 90 days in the shoe and that
with the hole is that the whole okay
yeah
i i take i wasn't in the shoe i was in
the hole what's the difference the shoes
are programmed like some people like my
uh one of my best friends my brother
evans he did 13 years in this shoe god
i'm still thinking 90 days in the hole
yeah how much out of that are you 24
what do you mean i mean how much like do
you get out at all five minutes nothing
nothing i mean they they let you shower
once a week in the normal week yeah we
just got a shower in your cell i mean in
the little yeah the little cell like a
bowl of water
it's crazy because there's like five
there's a ten by ten room how big is the
hole
smaller than this right uh
from this table to the wall that's it
uh from yeah right here just no maybe
here [ __ ] that's like a five by five
yeah and there's six there's a toilet
there there's your bed and then there's
just a door in your little area right
there and nothing you don't you don't
have no extra food
you don't have nonex
one book
yeah anything to write with no probably
yeah like that little ass pencil you get
for like questionnaires at whole foods
so what are you doing to to keep your
mind sane i'm [ __ ] working out yeah
not jokes like
like
thinking of any you're allowed to get
mail i remember getting mail once oh i'm
gonna forget that letter for 90 days of
darkness and solitude
and then like
under so the doors are kind of
so if this is the floor this is the door
and then i just started going under the
door hey well so who else is in here
you try to get staged
hey y'all how many all out there smoke
yeah we smell all right
yeah
oh my god hang on i started telling
jokes to those fools i was just like
what's up homie hey li i i remember
doing i was like hey homie it's hard
doing comedy in prison they're like why
i'm like everybody's so captive
one of the homies was like yeah my tooth
hurts too egg oh no not a cavity cap
[ __ ] covered on captive i've been
recommending that everyone listen to the
how to buy a home podcast and so many of
you have already listening and already
on your way to buying a home in fact
david is an incredible episode that just
dropped last week where he interviewed
this young guy who happens to be a
honeydew listener all right a year ago
he had no job zero credit and the bank
denied his home loan and then he heard
about the how to buy a home podcast
because of the honeydew and he contacted
david now he's closed on a 200 000 3
bedroom home with a two-car garage and a
huge basement on a half acre i know
buying a home in today's market feels
impossible but it's not you've got to
check out the how to buy a home podcast
if you haven't started listening yet
david can help you too it's an
incredible resource for anyone who's
interested in buying a home whether
that's in the next month next year or in
five years and who knows 2022 could be
the year that you finally own your own
place host david cedoni has been helping
first-time buyers like us for years i'm
telling you if you're thinking about
buying a home next month next year and
five years listen to the how to buy a
home podcast today david can help find
how to buy a home wherever you listen to
podcasts whether it's saving more and
spending less getting organized or
losing weight there's a lot of
worthwhile goals to set for yourself
this year at the top of my list is
learning a new language with babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions i told you
all already before they even came to me
i was already using babel because i
believe in babel been learning my
spanish brushing up on it and not only
is learning a new language a fun and
engaging new hobby you can use it while
traveling the whole babel process is
addictively fun fast and easy babel
teaches
bite size language lessons for the real
world use okay so when i take my lessons
i'll do my lesson
um they'll speak it to me in a male and
a female voice then you have to write it
back so you're constantly redoing it and
you know
repeating steps and hearing it in
different ways and it really that really
helps babel's 15 minute lessons make it
the perfect way to learn a new language
on the go other language learning apps
use ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babble in addition to lessons you
can access podcasts games video stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
honeydew that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code honeydew babel language for life
now let's get back to the do yeah man
that was the whole that [ __ ]
what did you learn about yourself in
those 90 [ __ ] days
i should that's a great question i i
learned that uh
patience is everything
uh light is beautiful yeah people are
beautiful
uh
it uh
nah man like it's all kinds of [ __ ] i
was in the hole because i was in a riot
and the riot had to happen it had to
happen and i'm not one of those guys
that's like oh i was there no i i i was
like i'm gonna it doesn't matter what
kind of guy you are when you're in
prison you are now in a brand new place
and it i i watch this documentary hbo
it pissed me off a little bit because um
there was this it was like a white nerdy
kid and he wrote a bunch of bad checks
but they put him in
a violent prison
maximum security because of the amount
yeah and the lawyer kept saying you
can't throw this kid in with the killers
and [ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ] kill him
and that's exactly they didn't kill him
what they did is made him help
so one dude was stabbing another dude
and they made him hold the guy's legs
he was in there for bad checks now he's
now he's in for life for murder in
prison and they just made this guy hold
the dude's legs while he and again it
was violent they had the video of it and
you're just it's like the dude stabbed
him like 60 times or something but but
again they're reminding you like this is
a guy who raped and killed people that's
dying so
but
then he joins a band in prison i'm like
we i'm at the music center we can't get
instruments for these kids these people
stealing them out of here doing the
riots this [ __ ] is playing the
bass guitar in prison get the [ __ ] out
of here man there's only one guitar
i had three strings
[Laughter]
but um but yeah he was this nerdy kid
that did and that's what i'm saying you
could end up in there you could easily
end up in there that's why i'm so i
don't ever want to i'm scared of it
so the riot had to happen because you're
in prison and if that's what's going to
happen then you're either with it or
you're dead well yeah i mean yeah i mean
you're not dead
there's a there's going to be a price to
pay you're not you know what i mean yeah
and uh but i was kind of what
as stupid as it sounds right i was with
it i was still i'm 30 years old and i
was like
man i'm i'm [ __ ] shot off sundays
i was just like you know what [ __ ] this
shot i need to let these fools know
what's up so what happens in a riot all
hell
all hell and are they they're not firing
in on you guys or anything like that or
you're getting as much as you can before
they lock it all down the riot i did was
in the county
okay and it was all bad it was just
us versus everybody because everybody
everybody we were sick of what the [ __ ]
we were getting treated in there and
we're like we're not gonna have this
[ __ ] no more so we all woke up early as
[ __ ]
and what do you do
you just [ __ ] get up how many of you
guys
there was maybe
let me see
i would say there's about 150 in that
dorm total people
and there was probably
80 mexicans so half of you guys against
everybody else yeah but everybody else
was like we're
we're helping you too
yeah you're like oh hd honeydew no
that's down homie
are you mexican i am today
i am today
and [ __ ] bro
so
we lived in these uh
it's a big-ass dorm and they have like
foxtrot
alpha beta see like
places where you live they house like 15
to 16 people
i was living in foxtrot f
they found me in b
is that far away like wow i wasn't even
supposed to be where the tables were and
yeah but it was kind of an honor because
like
they came in the cops came in with
[ __ ] uh those uh rubber bullets are
they what are they gas
all the shields no worse battering ram
[ __ ] worse first what the [ __ ] is it
that came in with like a
pepper spray but like size of fire
extinguishers i've seen those the ones
they use on the capitol riders and [ __ ]
yeah and then they had paintball
pellets that had
mace in them oh [ __ ]
and i had so many welts on me
and
i just remember though like so they when
they come in everyone stay where the
[ __ ] you are you have to investigate
and then they're like what the hell are
you doing over here i was like you know
you make up an excuse dude i woke up
people were fighting i ran i ran and
they're like okay
i'm they're like why do you have all
these welts on you i was like you guys
shot me
like and they're like why are your hands
out this is from that riot damn yeah
like it was going down bro it was going
down and they took me away and people
are just like get down shotgun get down
homie and i was like why weren't you
guys with me like like okay i'll see
y'all fools i'll see y'all i'll see you
later i'll see you later and then like
people who don't go
they're the ones that were like oh no no
no i i got i didn't think so whatever
yeah bro that was what did they do then
do they add more time to your sentence
for you no they have to investigate and
then
they sent me to the hall i lost they
knew they were like no
and then they put you in a red jumpsuit
you do your 90 days yeah cause now
you're a violent like
hey this might he'll do some [ __ ]
and
yeah bro but being in the hall
i
got away from everybody i wrote all my
family and uh
it was kind of like hey homie you know
what's gonna happen every time and
i mean i'm with the business bro if
there's a riot i'm i'm going but there
was no need to be
more aggressive than i had to be after
that
that time in solitude did you envision
yourself back on stage did you were you
saying to yourself when i'm out of here
i'm gonna go
do comedy do the right thing or were you
worried you'd be back there
what were you thinking
none of that nothing no i was just more
like [ __ ] i let my kids down they were
gonna come visit me now you you're
denied all that [ __ ] three months now
you don't even get to see your kids yeah
and like
it suck man because my son was in sixth
grade at that time and i have custody of
him
and we were just like he'd always write
and he was just like
what happened and i was like i'll see
you at visiting
like i can't explain this [ __ ] through a
letter and i just remember seeing him he
was just like hey man i don't have a mom
all i have is you what are you gonna do
and i was like
all right i'll be home i'll be home
don't trip and then
yeah man
you know your friends and your family
can't check you but your kids can
you know what i mean by that and you
just do a certain thing and from there
on on i do know what you mean by that
yeah i was like you know what george
there's no more reason to be hard
[ __ ] nowhere it doesn't hit
like the way it does when you're kid
yeah
you know
it's crazy like my son to this day still
lives with me
and he's always like hey remember you
drew this for me in prison i was like
you kept all this [ __ ] and he's like dad
i loved it
and i like i'm i go i'm not going to lie
i didn't draw that for that paste
i painted some raised announcements
for an artist
[Laughter]
oh
you know it's a trip though as i was
locked up with some crazy gangster named
rascal he's from la marana
that's the la mirada
i got it i got it i've been out here
long enough i can order a taco bell
and he was a tattoo artist and hardcore
gangster i was going to ask you do you
have any how many prison tats all all of
them yeah except for i think i might
have asked you that last year yeah this
one is my mom's name she passed away i
got her in a rose
and
yeah that's it and oh no but rascal did
these when he got out like his his life
is doing great
he owns his own tattoo shop now
like hey bro it's a it's a trip when
you're locked up with someone and then
you see them rehabilitated and get out
and do it and do it yeah
like did i tell you by the time i got
locked up at the dodger game
i mean no i don't think so you said it
to me before we got on and i was like
shut up and don't say another word
why what you do at the dodger game so
we're in those cheap ass seats the ones
like where you can see the [ __ ]
dozens yeah yeah when you can't tell if
it's a foul ball or a home run for a
minute yeah you're like hang on
all right like you know you dare catch
it you're like
you just wait to get hit by the ball
and uh we were drunk and [ __ ] and we
were throwing [ __ ] on the field and
we were just being dumb masses we were
the girls and the girls we were with are
pushing people and uh yeah they have a
jail in dodger stadium they got i think
in all stadiums but wait you got you so
you're being you were drunk and throwing
[ __ ] on the field what inning
i think it was the fifth or the sixth
i got out ninth inning
wait so they take you down to the jail
and you get out yeah
and they realize that like
we really weren't doing [ __ ] they were
containing us
and like i'm
not on parole i'm not it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] like i wasn't even thinking
about it like how stupid were you to let
these fools lock you up like hey dawg
you're not even a cut like the hot dog
fools locked us up
that's how [ __ ] drunk we were
[ __ ]
because i'll tell you what for that
minimum wage i hold [ __ ] the hot dog guy
gotcha
yeah
man prison
it sucks right now too ryan
uh the system's bad bro like
on a level two in one yard those yards
that were like for people to go home
they're no good no more what i mean no
good is they have the snitches they're
called sny yards
special need yards okay like you got
snitches molesters
[ __ ] people that are chomos and all
that [ __ ] people that have done a crime
if they put them with people like me
they'll be killed
so now they're like well if you want to
go home you have to stay on this yard
but then you're no good no more so it's
all bad it's all bad bro like
say you're doing 20 years and you're on
your 18th year now
you're like you know what ryan your
points have dropped
now you can get visits with your family
and hug them and [ __ ] but you're like i
can't go to that yard
i can't sleep with the molester i can't
have like yeah it's all bad man
hey shout out to all the homies doing
time
stay safe fellas stay on that three yard
and just do that hard time at the end
cause say you go to that level two yard
now you gotta beat that guy up so
they'll take you off the yard and you
just added eight months to your sense i
see
yeah
yeah
if you were in prison you'd handle bro
it's just your style
listen i i believe
i would hope where i was put i could
hold myself hold my own
but you put me on those with the i'm i'm
almost 50. you put me in there with some
24 year old [ __ ] monster [ __ ] it i'll
take the ass weapon i'll take it yeah i
ain't gonna do nothing yeah i might get
his eye i would go for an eye something
yeah but also i wouldn't start any [ __ ]
i'm that way in life i mind my own
business i don't want to look over here
and even see what you're doing i hear
horror stories about people walking by
and looking in now you saw what they
were doing get your ass in here you're
doing this heroin too because if you
don't you're going to tell on us and
we're going to [ __ ] kill you now
you're doing whatever in that cell i
hear all kinds of stories well you don't
have to do the heroine but it's more
like we get like you said there's gonna
be a price to that yeah yeah yeah that
that ah [ __ ] i feel bad i don't know if
i've ever said this [ __ ] you always
bring the [ __ ] out of me dude
you'd be
you'd be like the best guy for 48. like
all right i need to know everything
right
so
i was at this prison man and there was
this
white guy that was
poor guy he was older man like 64. his
name was wesley he was from compton
originally like the og's yeah i was
gonna say he must be 64. he's probably
70. okay 476 now he was in there for
attempted murder
got a divorce
started drinking he's he's he's a not a
puny but he's a little guy
and then somebody made fun of him
afterwards and they beat him up they
pissed on him they took his money and so
he
broke a bottle went in there and stabbed
that [ __ ] damn
yeah and now he's
staying
i was in a dormitory my last year
because my points dropped is that your
own cell no still sharing no now i'm
living in the barracks with a hundred
inmates and it's just open open oh okay
like get on the navy right yep and it's
like that and it rock and rolls and uh
this full he was i'm allowed to have a
white
or a med skin full sleep under me
if not i'm not sleeping there and shit's
gonna happen it's what it is it's what
it is it's the politics
and so one night i had my cell phone and
i was i was it was my fault bro i
shouldn't have been as loud as i was
because he had to go to work he was uh
he worked for the x for the dental x
they have dentists in prison okay and he
was the x-ray guy that went yeah
and he had juice and i didn't i could
have used them but i was like this poor
white man
and then uh one night he wakes up
in front of everybody dog there's all of
us right there all of us and he's like
hey shotgun i'm like good morning he's
like [ __ ] what do you mean good
[ __ ] morning you [ __ ] kept me up
all [ __ ] night all this [ __ ] and
i just looked at this fool and
everybody's looking at me like
oh [ __ ] someone just called out shotgun
he was sitting on the bottom bunk
putting his [ __ ] shoe on talking [ __ ]
to me and i just [ __ ] jumped off my
bunk
i [ __ ] kicked him in the
[ __ ] face
this is why i never want to go to prison
because he had to say something and you
had to do something that's what i'm
saying i don't even want to be in prison
yet and then i get the [ __ ] mindset i
don't want to be there and i remember
just going
you say one more word dog i'm not gonna
stop and then all the whites were like
[ __ ] we have to back up our homie
and all the mets guns were like jump and
then [ __ ] i was like i don't have the
power but i was just like hey homie it
was a misunderstanding
you know if you guys want to punish me
i'm down and then he's like no one's
punishing you this [ __ ]
disrespected you and you did what you
had to do
and then like it was weird for cause i
had to sleep with this for later
did he hey did he go fix his own teeth
[Music]
he's in their self-doubt as [ __ ]
x-rays oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you are a savage
that's the guy i'd be in prison saying
[ __ ] like that and i get beat my sleep
for talking [ __ ] this is the [ __ ] up
part
i saw like he didn't even go to eat he
was embarrassed he thought his people
were going to punish him
because he didn't fight back or whatever
and i just i went up to the white ramp i
said hey homie he wasn't misunderstood
the rep i love him yeah guys got a
little name no he don't have a name tag
yeah
i told that for aomi
like i apologize i shouldn't have to
apologize but this old man's going home
in a year
i don't think he's ever had to deal with
someone like me so i apologize but if
anything let's let me know he's like no
no no he's like we're going to tax him i
said that's what i don't want you guys
to do
you know what's that tack something you
said they're gonna beat his ass oh
that's attack attacks that ass yeah and
i was like okay and i don't and i don't
i i don't have no power and i'll just
like hey dawg i mean 68 yeah and a bunch
of young strong [ __ ] are gonna
roll on us yeah people are already being
killed at that prison i was at for
getting texts because you fight in the
restroom and it's all tile and if you
fall back it's a wrap so
i i remember like i was working the yard
crew
i just remember like [ __ ] man i feel
like a dick like i went to breakfast and
people were like oh [ __ ] and you know
the whole prison knew oh [ __ ] george
kicked they made [ __ ] up oh george
kicked some white boy in the face you
did a backflip rolled in someone else's
bed pretending to sleep
and like
hey bro [ __ ] gossip all day i just
remember coming back and i just go hey
homie let me talk to you real quick and
he was just like yeah yeah his head down
all scattered like dog you don't have to
be like that but you put me in a
position
now i apologize to you but that's it
here's a [ __ ] cigarette if you want
to there's two tickets to the comedy
store
i promise you they're gonna be good
someday you could park here by spot
i i want to find this for cause he was
cool man
yeah that's like my whole like now let
me ask you i i like it so you got a
heart in there it hurts bro it hurts
cause i i still had to do
i still did four to five months of this
whole sleeping under me and he didn't
talk to me ever after that
he was just like
i bet he didn't say [ __ ] to him
that's the lesson he learned
what um all right so here's
what would have happened if you didn't
do anything to him
uh now i didn't do anything to him yeah
if he talked [ __ ] like that i probably
would have got
stabbed by your own yeah for not
sticking up straight up no it would have
been like this like if
the big homie would have been like hey
come here real quick let's go to the
vinyl what the [ __ ] all right right
there all right you need to get taken
care of or you need to go handle that
right now and you're still going to get
taken care of because you didn't do it i
had to tell you yeah yeah but i was
never that guy there was a guy in there
though that [ __ ] was don king
what do you mean he was like a promoter
dog he was he was just like hey check
this out
somebody was talking bad about you
i heard it and he was willing to put
himself on the line like hey we'll go
over there
and i was like who's talking [ __ ] on me
goes that fool he goes you want to fight
him i said yeah yeah yeah and he was all
right he goes on i'm the only one
allowed in there and we were fighting
the restroom and nobody beat his ass for
this nah he was like
this full was like 6 4
2 30. oh okay like he's already been in
prison for 16 years
and like no homo he was beautiful man
he was telling me stories that he was
locked up since he was like 12. so he's
never seen the sun he doesn't have no
sugar in them no saul so he's healthy
[Laughter]
and his whole body i've been waiting for
the silver lining here without prison in
there yeah his whole body was
women doing sexual [ __ ] there's tattoos
yeah and i'd just be like and then i
remember he'd always be like he goes
yeah homie [ __ ] only person i love is my
mom ain't [ __ ] that [ __ ] my mom's been
visiting me since i was 10. this phone
told me he used to [ __ ] him when he was
little
in juvenile hall yeah he was like he's
like you just got to cut a whole butter
in the ring
he's putting butter
and then the funniest [ __ ] he goes yeah
he's like
he goes i like fat [ __ ] when i get
out hug with the fat [ __ ] cause they
smell like those hams
this dude is [ __ ] up
did i even tell you about the time that
i seen a prison guard that i was locked
up with at a [ __ ] show that i was at
i don't know i don't remember it downey
doing an underground comedy show one of
the prison guards was there he remember
you he just goes hey you're george perez
i said yeah and he goes
you remember me and i was like nah you
like a fan or something
and he just went like show me his gun he
goes hey man i have to let you know that
like you were in my prison
i have to leave dog but i'm just letting
you know that i'm strapped and i was
like
homie i go up next oh he didn't know you
were a comic
i was like i'm going on stage is that
really what they have to do legally oh i
didn't know that i don't think they have
to tell you but he was just more like
because he see me there with a group of
people and i was just like [ __ ] that
must be a hard job yeah also to remember
everybody i feel like the term remember
your [ __ ] hi yeah no you'll
remember bro you'll remember so he was
strapped in did he watch you no no he
left yeah because i probably told in his
head he goes [ __ ] they know i'm a cop
i see yeah you that would blow his cover
yeah
i i think that's the hardest job ever a
cop
imagine that you have to wear a camera
to work
yeah and it records everything you do
and say i wasn't this is hard enough
this hour's hard enough to say [ __ ] not
to get canceled
yeah
yeah i couldn't imagine that yeah [ __ ]
that all right so now you do three years
did you do all three uh since it was a
violent crime you have to do 85 of your
time so i did three years and you know
two years and like nine months all right
so talk to me about getting out like
what is it like that week
leading up to getting out they give you
a up a duck it's called the s ducket
because when you're in prison you have a
card and that card lets you know
where you're supposed to be so between
one o'clock and two o'clock
george is allowed to be by the cafeteria
because he works there
he's allowed to go to yard at this time
because he doesn't have no work so they
give you an s ducat that's letting all
the cops know oh you're going home in
two weeks okay cool yeah go go what i
mean
like you don't have to go to work no
more i don't have to work look this is
why because if you don't go to work
they'll [ __ ] give you more time more
like they'll
give you this any [ __ ] up is more time
called the 115. it's like
a what's that [ __ ] called a citation
mm-hmm
and uh i just remember man
my
my real close homie in those last months
was some guy named little man solid as
[ __ ] he
he just he's doing it 18 years he was
locked up since he was 15 for murder
and he was just like hey dog
you're representing us like when you go
out there now you don't have to be this
gangster be you but you don't have to be
hitting fools up blasting like go out
there let the world know where you we're
funny we have a sense of humor let them
know that gangsters homies trolls
chicanos like we can we're funny dog and
i was kind of like like everybody was
cheering for me bro it was kind of cool
man
but that [ __ ] walk i'll never forget
that day out yeah i got it at least
what do you do now you don't sleep are
you okay go back to my first question
the first night you finally did sleep
were you by yourself because the dude
was out of the cell or did you have to
sleep with this dude i had to sleep with
him for like two weeks what is that like
it's weird bro is it loud or is it quiet
it's quiet as a [ __ ] there's a
penalty for talking after there is oh
yeah and so how do people communicate is
it quiet whisper is it notes bagging for
like how do you talk to your cell mate
there's no whispering at all it it'll
they'll hear it huh yeah so you just
pass a little letter under
but there's really you're really not
even trying to do that right you don't
want to bring no attention to yourself
are they walking by are there cameras
there's cameras and they're walking in
the cell there's cameras no outside got
it and uh
yeah i just room there's no pillow
there's no pillow i guess no i mean that
is a luxury i guess huh especially there
cause
yeah [ __ ] man all right so now the week
you're going out you can't sleep you're
so [ __ ] excited are they letting
visits happen during that week or is it
like now you'll be home i mean visits
are
assigned to you
through like you have a
a correction a number they give you mine
was f99587
and those last three numbers are are
like
everyone gets a week in the month
so i had the third week of the month and
my [ __ ] already passed
as i got released
i got released the day before
thanksgiving it's all holiday based huh
yeah christmas eve and then the day
before thanksgiving all right so what
happens thanksgiving eve to me honest to
god it's a great night [ __ ] yeah it can
be a great night
damn dude you're making me like almost
tear up right
now ah
who picks you up
i'll i'll get to that
everyone's sad dog they don't want you
to leave
fools are like
where are you going homie
it's just i got a year left do it with
me i'm like i can't dog like i gotta go
and i just remember like
this is where you
people know who you are everything you
said what are you gonna be accountable
so i told everyone hey i had jordans in
there i had levi's nice jacket clean
undershirts so i go help me i said i
went up to everybody i said look here's
that jacket i promise here's that watch
here's it i go because when i leave here
i can get all this [ __ ] you guys can't
here's my radio here's my tv i left
everything and people were like get down
homie get down and then
i remember just having the bomb ass
dinner i didn't sleep bro i was just
chilling with my homeboy little man and
we're just talking and he's just like
hey dog like you're what are you gonna
do and i was like i don't know
i'm scared were you yeah i was like i
don't know what i'm gonna do is that
what you were scared about like
i didn't know i was gonna live the girl
was like hey if you find that job within
three days i'll let you live with me i
was like what
three days
yeah
and uh
there's always rumors that people are
like hey full sun foals have beef on you
this is what i wanted to ask you is
there truth to the people want to
[ __ ] trip you up and try to sweat you
before you go out so they i've seen it
happen to people
i seen it happen yeah where fools are
like not home you owe money you're not
going nowhere oh okay and i was just
like i don't know no money and
that's when the guards like perez
bunk 32 and i was like
i ain't gonna lie i wanted to run
because i didn't want to walk through
that and they're like everyone's like
hey come here give me a hug give me a
hug give me a hug [ __ ] yeah hold me hey
hey here's my address all right oh yeah
yeah yeah
and then you have to walk
the whole prison you have your little
brown bag
tore up ass clothes i took whatever was
worse because they have mail outs your
family mails you clothes you can wear
when you leave
and then
i'm in a cell like this big it's a wire
it's a wire oh uh cell with a chain
fence
and they're like hey you're gonna go
home in two hours
there's a black guy in there there's an
asian in there there's a white guy in
there i'm pretty sure you guys are gonna
fight he's like what do you want to do
you want to be by yourself in the closet
or you want to go on that stuff
i said i'm cool i'll go on the sale i'm
going home you know
put my clothes on and [ __ ] everyone said
they give you 200
that's more than comedy clubs give you
[Laughter]
hey that's some [ __ ] you've been doing
nothing but time
oh and uh
you know everything runs through your
head bro
my daughter was the most precious thing
i wanted to see because like
when i wasn't my girlfriend was pregnant
when i went to prison so i didn't even
get to see my daughter be more man
really i met my daughter on my birthday
on the first prison visit i ever had
wow how old was she at that time
days weeks
six seven months months okay
what was that like it was crazy dude she
but it was she was so it she was the
thing that you hold her yeah yeah you
could hold her in prison i didn't know
that yeah
and uh
so uh you're waiting bro you're just
like hey dog like you guys said i could
leave why am i still in this we waited
for two hours
and then finally they were like i
remember talking to my my girlfriend the
day before and she's like hey we're
gonna be in the parking lot in this car
and like
they open a [ __ ] fence
and they're like eiffel it is like that
on that big slide yeah oh and they're
like look
you cannot hang out in this [ __ ]
parking lot
you cannot be cause there's there's
houses by my prison like there's like
it's it's
society civilians there's a park across
the street that's crazy yeah but
everybody knows when you escape you
don't kick it you go yeah so they ain't
scared and uh
oh
i just remember like all right cool man
and then they open the next gate and
they're like hey find your family and
get the [ __ ] out of here or get in our
van we'll take you to the greyhound and
you can go somewhere
and i don't know where my my
girlfriend's like hey
oh dog it's crazy like you get in the
car and [ __ ] of course you crying [ __ ]
you know my crying and [ __ ] oh my god
you're home you're free and i was like
yeah yeah you know please can we leave
can we leave is your daughter there too
should you bring your daughter your son
too no my sons and then they're like nah
cause they didn't when my sons would
visit me they're like hey dad i don't
like the visits they strip search you
they got guns on top like watching strip
search the people coming in of course
they do right
don't go through this [ __ ] no more
i just remember being on the freeway and
my girlfriend was
tripping because i was like hey is it
okay if i roll the because i'm used to
asking someone to do she's like why the
[ __ ] you asking if you could roll the
one down and i was like scared that's
interesting yeah how long did it take
you to transition out of that sort of
mentality
i don't know maybe a year yeah and
she was like hey we're gonna go to your
my brother was watching my son from i
have two other sons one of them lives
with his mom my other son with his
brother
and we just went over there and
they were like oh dad and
it's crazy for a lot of crying a lot of
like hey i'm sorry and then they took me
to disney walk and i almost [ __ ] lost
it
hey i'm rip dog i was doing like
yeah your best shape your life yeah
and i'm [ __ ] over there [ __ ]
disney walk
sure enough
[ __ ] are rude stepping on my
shoes there's people on my and then my
sons just hug me
i was just like wait hey come here real
quick you [ __ ] just stepped on my
[ __ ] homies
and i remember the guy was like i'm
pushing my stroller sorry
he was like
excuse me
[Laughter]
and then my son's seen it and they're
like let's get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
like thank you we went to a mexican
restaurant i got drunk off one beer
yeah i bet your tolerance is nice
and amen
let me ask you this how long
before you really were able to like let
your shoulders down you know not just
finally
i don't know if i have yet
i've i've talked to guys in prison and
they said it's something they never do
no i i've ne they they i've i've taught
the guys that were like if you see a
dude that's always like this he's
probably served time and i'm like that's
interesting you just never really can
yeah drop all the way i mean at the
house yeah but like but still there's
always check this out i haven't
kicked it with the black dude
in three years and my homeboy stephen
fly
he was like yo player i heard you're out
yeah
and he was just like yo you want a
cigarette i'm like yeah but i can't
smoke after you like i just i've been
taught these rules he was like man [ __ ]
your ass up dog and i just like hey hold
me up i'm uncomfortable right now please
he was just like
oh [ __ ] like it was hey bro it was weird
man like
i didn't yeah
when did you first do comedy after
you're out how long
three months three months what was that
like
well
i did it
how can i say this
russell peters is so dope yeah he is
he's coming done on the show yeah you
know he found out
he was just like yo uh
you want to do nokia theater oh my god
are you telling me you went from prison
to doing theaters like that with russell
you went from like a 6x6 south of the
nokia theater holy [ __ ] that's a mine
right there i know
three months out of prison you're doing
no shows like that i did a show with him
three weeks and then i got scared out of
prison yeah i did the laugh factory he
was like hey come come and i was like
all right
and then he was like hey we're doing
nokia theater and i was kind of like it
wasn't enough that wasn't around before
i got locked up no it wasn't and i was
like the phone company has a
nokia
it's a theater
and then uh
yeah
that was some shocking ass [ __ ] i got
scared and i'm hey i'm ripped
i i have a model body and russell's like
hey
here's an outfit for the show
so guess who's at the show in the green
room alyssa milano no
i got pictures dog uh
the original mystique
the girl
[ __ ] it rebecca romines damos
demos
uh rosoli file the rizzoli the girls
from rizzoli files on tnt show
and
yeah dog and like
i just remember like being hit on by
successful people and russell going
and this fool was stabbing people two
months ago
yeah
yeah and then like after that
my girlfriend got real jealous and she
was just like hey i don't think you
should be going out you're on parole
like i broke parole because i've spoke i
wasn't allowed to leave
i could only be like i said 50 mile
radius and also are you allowed to be in
a place that has alcohol and live
entertainment that's not violating
people yeah no parole i wasn't a drug
offender enough got it they were just
like they would search my house for
weapons and i couldn't be around another
parolee
and yeah but [ __ ] russell dog that
[ __ ] was dope yeah that's what a what a
360. yeah i should say 180. yeah yeah
god damn and then joey diaz was funny
like hey bro i mean
i'm doing the brayer improv i only live
10 minutes from there and he was like
you want to come do a quick 10 minutes
full makes me headline when i get there
and but he was just like hey bro i i
know what you're going through george
break out of this [ __ ] break stop
he's like your wife's gonna try to make
it do construction all this [ __ ] no
you're a [ __ ] comedian remember like
and kill bill where he's trying to [ __ ]
you're over here trying to get married
to a record guy you're a killer this is
what you do joey sent me back out and i
was like you know what thanks though
you're right you're right cause i i
sucked those first 15 minutes on stage
and then the cop the comic came out of
me was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] go off the
top now start fruit and then i was like
it felt good again you know because when
i did a russell show it was all my job i
went over all my old jokes it was i
didn't even test myself
and it was they're all gonna laugh they
thought i was indian and [ __ ]
they did
i was dressed in russell's expensive ass
she got me like a gucci outfit and i was
like they're like oh [ __ ] this whole
indian too
that's great man yeah what a story dude
thank you for uh coming on here and
sharing i'm sure that was wasn't easy to
talk about some of that stuff man thank
you nah man i'm glad though bro i'm glad
you're out i'm glad you changed
joey redband like you guys i don't ever
talk like this to my kids or nothing i
don't want them to know now they're
going to know because they watch yeah
thanks man like hey dog it's it's good
man you know there's a lot of talented
people that are in prison bro
i was locked up with the guy and i
remember that you know that show snow on
fox
there's a show on fox uh john singleton
direct said it's huge the that fool was
in my prison dorm one of the main actors
oh really yeah but
yeah right he was in the riot that i was
in so we don't talk
[Laughter]
love your show man [ __ ] you
uh dude promote whatever you'd like one
more time please
george perez follow me on twitter
instagram any
network george p comedy i got a podcast
called george perez stories every
tuesday night at 9 15 we drop an episode
i'm on tour with fool's gone wild and
funk freaks and
ladies only only over the age of 44 send
nudes
that's great dude
all right uh as always ryan sickler on
all social media ryan sickler.com we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you